hurricane laura
made landfall as a category 4 storm
ravaging through the southern states of
the us
now thousands of homes in texas and
louisiana
are submerged in water and many others
are severely damaged hundreds of
thousands of people were ordered
to evacuate but not everyone did
i stayed we have several pets and
everything and i stayed with
the cats and dogs it was wild
around one or so the wind picked up and
i could hear the the neighbor's roof
blew off the side of the house and just
blew this
blew into my house president trump says
he's planning to visit the affected gulf
coast
though not immediately i was going to
texas i was going to lose
louisiana maybe arkansas looks like
arkansas just spoke to the governor it's
going to be in pretty good shape but
they'll need some help but now it turned
out
we got a little bit lucky it was very
big it was very powerful but it passed
quickly
and so everything's on schedule we'll
probably be going on saturday or sunday
mr president i i just would encourage um
uh people to keep uh keep the people of
louisiana
and texas and now arkansas where you've
signed an emergency declaration as the
tropical storm
moves north keep them in your prayers
but also keep in mind
organizations like red cross that are
also on the ground that are providing
assistance and support
to all of the efforts for families
forecasters have warned of a continued
risk to lives as the storm moves inland
deeper into louisiana though it has now
considerably weakened
a chemical fire in the lake charles area
of louisiana has broken out
emergency crews are tackling it and the
governor has warned residents in the
area to shelter
the federal emergency management agency
says resources are in place to help
restore
services to affected areas in the weeks
and months ahead
matthew capucci meteorologist for the
washington post in port arthur texas
joins us now matthew thank you for being
with us hurricane laura was predicted to
hit somewhere between houston and new
orleans and bring with it
unsurvivable storm surges just how bad
was it
you know we had some good news and some
bad news with the storm it looks like
the storm surge may not have been quite
as bad
as originally anticipated some areas did
report about a three to four in
a meter increase in water level
associated with the surge so that is
pretty bad news but the good aspect of
this
was that that wasn't quite as bad as the
six to seven meter storm surge we were
anticipating at the same time
winds gusted upwards of 210 kilometers
per hour in spots
that caused widespread devastation and
that penetrated farther inland than
originally anticipated the windstorm
aspect of it
was much worse than we thought it would
be in fact like a 16 kilometer wide path
of total devastation from this eyewall
that came ashore
resulted in significant damage across
much of the area and
we saw some really significant
structural issues as well
and how does this compare to other
hurricanes you've seen in the past
you know to be honest this is one of the
most memorable wind storm events that
i've seen the entire eyewall was like a
60 kilometer
wide tornado with winds gusting upwards
of 210 kilometers per hour i was driving
down
interstate 10 westbound and it was just
free after tree after tree down in fact
it was pretty much
impassable unless you went to the far
left lane and tractor trailers were
toppled on their size
along the interstate and one thing that
really struck me was the magnitude of
the wind damage
in very narrow swaths i thought i saw
mobile homes
that were completely obliterated
demolished by the heavy winds
i saw gas station canopies that were
lofted and thrown
vehicles that were perhaps moved or
tipped over in the form of those 18
wheelers in the higher profile vehicles
and in addition extensive roof damage as
well
and one of the things that struck me the
most there was a steel truss
building an outbuilding of some sort
that looked to be an industrial complex
that was completely leveled collapsed by
the winds and these rims at this point
were only about 160 to 170 kilometers
per hour
so the fact that we're able to
accomplish these feats really tells you
a lot about how
long the wind stuck around up to three
hours at times and just how widespread
they were
but the hurricane has now been
downgraded in in category does that
mean the worst is over
[Music]
for the most part yes the good news is
that because it's far enough inland we
don't have to worry about any coastal
surge
anymore and i always tell folks run from
the water hide from the wind
the water right now not a big threat
because it's so far
inland but the wind still impressed in
many areas
gusts to around 90 or 100 kilometers per
hour as far north as the architects or
even a tennessee valley and there are
some weather models
that indicate the propensity for this
storm to actually track with
a little bit of a wind signature all the
way to the east coast
so gusty winds likely intensity in ohio
valleys in the coming days
and then the chance this storm can
actually become reinvigorated off the
east coast
and form into a tropical storm once
again sometime in the saturday into
early sunday time frame
now so far in this hurricane season
there have been three
already been three ferocious hurricanes
why is the current uh
season so active i mean this started in
june
exactly you know on average we typically
see us reach the l or the m
names and we've already reached the m
names but but we're talking for an
entire season so we've seen a season's
worth of hurricanes
so far in just 2020. we're about 200
percent
and more active than normal in terms of
the amount of energy output by the
oceans
and one thing that concerns me even
though we just had these two storms
rolled through
the atlantic is still well above average
in terms of water temperatures
with many areas around 32 or 33 degrees
and that is just a powder keg in terms
of the atmosphere
to get another thing i'm seeing right
now a convectively coupled kelvin wave
basically a big area of rising motion
over the atlantic
and that will favor an increased
development chains of storms in the
coming weeks and it looks to pedal back
mid to late september early october
but then in the middle to later portions
of october
likely to rage again so several
additional peaks
within this hurricane season of enhanced
activity and increased likelihood of
storms
but it looks like this season is just
right for development and that does not
look to slow down anytime
soon okay comprehensive insight there
matthew capucci
thank you thank you
you